listen a dwarf can play a dwarf part but
I think it's important to change
narratives that don't fit in today's
society and really which is that
narrative it might be better
for normal roles everywhere because they
do exist what was so bad about the way
dwarves are depicted in Snow White have
I missed something well that listen I'm
not that's that's right that's what I'm
kind of wondering is I don't represent
Disney but I'm just saying I think I see
their point of view what's their point
of view what was so bad about the
depiction of that why are you so happy
about a movie changing with the times
and moving forward because I think
honestly there is real news we could be
discussing no but this is real news if
you're a dwarf actor who are not out of
work because of virtue signaling idiots
but you're just using this everything
has to be reread you want you to be
inclusive it's not inclusive at all